hi this is steve kaufman here again um i
did um a video a little while ago about
about speaking and and um
you know answering the question how do
you get from this sort of passive
input based learning to actually
speaking
and
you know i am a believer in in a lot of
input and many people and of course it's
easy to do it has a lot of practical
advantages you can read when you want
you can listen when you want you can
listen when you do other things and all
of that is helping the brain get used to
a new language
i've said that i'm not a great fan of
implicit instruction and so forth but
one thing is for sure when you are
listening and when you are reading
you don't notice everything that's going
on in the language
uh so you need
to start to notice
and uh i'm gonna kind of go through i'm
gonna again as always i don't write
these things out so they're kind of
rambling and
i talk a lot about my own experience
which might be different from the
experience of others
but
the way i see it is
when i start a language
it's very difficult to notice anything
you're sort of
deep in this
dark well
and everything is dark and unclear and
and the first thing that i can start to
notice is words
by listening a lot
and of course by having the text
available to read
and by having if it's a traditional
system there'll be a word list of words
and so i'll i will gradually start to
identify the words i will start to
notice the words
it may be that i'll notice that for
example
in russian instead of saying i have they
say to me is
and that'll sound strange and i don't
really quite understand
what
is happening from a grammatical point of
view but i know that they're saying
um
i have so i start to notice these basic
structures these basic components
and so for the first long while i'm just
noticing words and phrases helped along
by my reading
and if we're using link then helped
along by the words and phrases that i
have saved
and
i'm not very sophisticated at that point
in in how i
how i save different words and phrases i
don't i might try to tag a little bit by
you know parts of the body or something
but i tend not to do that because it's
all scattered i'm picking up little
pieces here and there
and and of course the first thing that
starts to happen is
the more you have already noticed and
the more you understand the more you're
able to notice other things
so things that completely passed you by
the first time the second time saying
listening to something first time you're
listening just for meaning and now the
next time you're starting to listen for
some of the words and phrases that you
have saved
so as you are more familiar with the
context you notice more things that
relate to the language in the same way
the same way the more of the language
you've already noticed the more
additional things you can notice i mean
we know for example people who have a
large vocabulary can easily pick up more
vocabulary just by inferring the meaning
we don't have to look everything up in
the dictionary if we have enough of a
base we start to get what the new words
mean
so so our gradually our vocabulary grows
in this way and and i believe that what
we do at link with with our our you know
linking creating links and reviewing
them and flash cards
as long as they come from content that
that helps you notice and then when we
highlight the words in yellow so that a
word you have already saved before and
you've forgotten
you see it again highlighted in yellow
it helps you notice
uh so now let's move on to grammar
certainly and i've always said one
should have a short grammar book
available
just to look through the first time you
look through it you get a very vague
sense of what happens in the language
you can't possibly remember the detailed
descriptions of the rules and their
exceptions because you don't have enough
knowledge in order to notice that you
don't have enough knowledge to
understand the explanations
at some point
you
like i'm finding now with russian i'm
starting to focus on cases i have a
vague sense of the cases i'm able to
infer the meaning because i know enough
words
and i'm always more motivated to learn
more words because that's what's holding
me back from understanding the
content that i'm listening to and
reading so i haven't invested an awful
lot of time in the grammar because it
doesn't prevent me from understanding
uh
given that my understanding is in any
case 60 70 80 90 depending on what the
context
is
but now i'm focusing more on grammar so
again i'm helping myself notice
by investing some time in the individual
words and phrases that i'm saving by
editing the little phrase that we
capture at link by tagging it as a
genitive or dative case and then
reviewing them all
together and then i see the captured
phrase which reminds me and all of this
is helping
i read the grammar explanation again i
have a table so that when i see this
item
i'm not sure whether it is data
regenerative or what it is in some cases
and of course depending on whether it's
masculine feminine and neuter the
endings can be all over the place so i
have a table that i refer to
can't remember the table to save my life
but i go back in and i mark this as
dative
and then i'll review it and it's i'm not
really learning it but i'm making myself
more alert more attentive so that i
start to notice
better
and so you know it's a bit like
i don't know we talk about science that
we are standing on the shoulders of
giants where
new scientists are coming up with new
discoveries because they already know so
much about science that was developed
by their predecessors the newtons and
the other uh thinkers of the world well
it's the same in in language we're
noticing
more in more detail a more
uh perhaps some more sophisticated
grammatical concepts because we have the
base that we have already noticed and we
already have so the more you know the
more you can know the more you know the
more you can learn
now noticing has been identified by
linguists and grammar teachers as a very
important part of language teaching i
discovered a blog i did some research on
the web and and the the conclusions seem
to be that you know uh crash and and i
agree with this crash and all by itself
is not enough you're just reading is not
going to do it
there is more that's happening there
so some people say well you can only
sort of learn from input if you have
explicit instruction in class i don't
believe that
that's not my experience i can't take
explicit instruction in class
i want to discover it on my own
on my own terms i don't want to be in a
classroom i don't want to be in
pairs having some kind of an artificial
dialogue with someone i don't want to do
those things
that's why maybe that's just me now i'm
very interested to have reactions from
other people i am sure that the
instructional class does help you notice
things it doesn't teach it to you
now another thing that helps you notice
is to make mistakes there's no question
but you don't want to be corrected too
often and you certainly don't improve
right away and i have this experience
all the time i had it just the other day
in a discussion where a learner said
i ever read this book and i said you
can't say i ever read what do you mean
and she gave me the word in chinese and
i said aha okay i have read the book
that's all we say we don't use that
chinese term jing we don't use that term
we just say i have read the book oh
thank you very much and then she went
right back and made the same mistake
again and it's not just her i had it
with people from all different uh
language groups you can correct them and
they go right back into making the same
mistake however you've chipped away a
little bit you've chipped away a little
bit at a pattern that they have that
maybe came from their first language
you've made them a little conscious and
then you may correct them again and they
may do it in writing and then maybe
they'll see it somewhere and at some
point all of a sudden they'll notice and
and because fundamentally you can't
develop the language just by speaking
you can't develop the language just from
within it has to come from outside it
has to come from what you hear and what
you read
but the question is how can you improve
the ability of the learner to notice
what's happening because if you don't
notice it
then you'll never be able to internalize
it and use it so i think that the a big
part of input-based learning is noticing
and there are a number of things that
will help you notice and those are the
again get back to link i mean those are
the kinds of activities that we have
built into link and there's more that
we're going to bring in
uh i think reading out loud helps you
notice
different people may have different
things that help them notice but we can
do things you know over and above this
the importance of liking the language
and choosing things that are interesting
and focusing on input and doing things
that are easy and not getting stressed
out and not worrying and all those other
things we should also do things to
increase our alertness
and to help us focus our attention on
things that matter and and we can change
that focus like right now i'm on to
cases in russian i may move to verbs
later on so that was a brief discussion
on this whole issue of noticing and i
look forward to hearing your opinions
thank you